la séance est ouverte l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion après engagement
de la procédure accélérée du projet loi
adopté par le Sénat relatif à
l'accélération d'un reconstruction et de
la réfection des bâtiments dégradés ou
détruits au cours des violences urbaines
survenues du 27 juin au 5 juillet 2023
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Béchu ministre de la transition
écologique et de la cohésion des
territoires
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente le président de
commission monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés
du 27 juin au 5 juillet
chacun s'en souvient 8 nuits de violence
de pillage un qualifiable ce sont
succédé dans notre pays avec un bilan
qui surpasse le triste précédent des
émeutes de 2005
chacun
en mémoire
le décès de ce jeune homme de 17 ans qui
a été
le fait déclencheur apparent
même si
[Musique]
dans la diversité des violences des
dégradations
c'est des pradations qui ont été
commises le lien avec cet événement
initial et quand même complexe et à
faire et à établir et on voit à quel
point ça a pu servir de prétexte à tout
autre chose
dans la continuité immédiate de ces
événements après que près de 500
communes ait été touché un titre ou un
autre le président de la République a
reçu les maires concernées à l'Elysée et
il a pris l'engagement de faire en sorte
que nous puissions
législativement poser les bases de ce
qui permettait d'accélérer la
reconstruction
projet de loi ce matin d'habilitation il
est l'occasion de tenir parole et de
joindre un geste d'unanimité de soutien
à nos élus
à nos services publics aux habitants qui
ont été frappés par ces nuits d'émeutes
et de violents sur Ben
en prenant un ensemble de mesures pour
faciliter la reconstruction matérielle
ce texte il a été voté à l'unanimité
avant-hier au Sénat et je n'ai pas de
doute que
l'intérêt général que nous avons en
partage le souci de montrer que le
dernier mot ne peut pas rester aux
émeutiers conduira votre assemblée a
adopter à l'unanimité aussi je l'espère
ce projet qui répond de manière concrète
et limitée
non pas aux causes mais aux conséquences
de ces émeutes
274 commissariats
brigade de gendarmerie ou poste de
police municipale attaquée sur
l'ensemble du territoire
105 mairies
243 établissements scolaires
47 établissements relevant du ministère
de la Justice 300 hospitaliers des bus
des trams des médiathèques des maisons
de quartier une crèche des gymnase des
maisons de la culture et même des locaux
associatifs
autant d'équipements au temps de service
indispensables pour nos concitoyens pour
lesquels nos collectivités
la collectivité nationale que nous
formons ont beaucoup investi dans la
durée et pour l'avenir de tous
et puis bien sûr il y a eu ces attaques
ignoble un qualifiable contre les forces
de l'ordre contre les pompiers appeler
pour secourir et contenir les
destructions contre les élus contre leur
famille qui sont tous un titre ou un
autre l'incarnation de notre République
et qui ont été ciblés comme tel
je n'oublie pas les milles commerces
vandalisés et pillés
les gérants de café les employés ou les
propriétaires de commerce de proximité
les pharmaciens bref toutes celles et
tous ceux
qui mènent une vie droite et honnête et
qui pourtant durant ces nuits ont perdu
le fruit de leur labeur un emploi un
outil de travail un véhicule quand ce
n'était pas de fruits des économies de
toute une vie
projet de loi il l'occasion de dire que
nous ne lâchons rien face à ceux que le
spectacle de la destruction facile
réjouit
ce projet de loi est l'occasion de dire
que nous sommes au côté de ceux qui
doivent rebâtir
je le conseille bien volontiers ce texte
est une brique essentielle mais n'est
qu'une partie de la réponse
brique essentielle pour effacer les
stigmates de ses émeutes pour permettre
à chacun de repartir de l'avant mais
qui clairement
renvoie à la rentrée le débat que nous
devons avoir sur les causes de Soyons
causé ses émeutes et les décisions que
nous aurons à prendre pour éviter
qu'elle ne puisse recommencer
le droit actuel offre une partie de
l'arsenal dont nous avons besoin pour
reconstruire c'est l'esprit de la
circulaire de la première ministre
présentée il y a deux semaines qui
mobilise pleinement la réalisation des
opérations de reconstruction et de
réflexion cependant
il est impératif d'aller plus loin pour
faciliter cette reconstruction et c'est
donc l'objet des trois articles qui sont
autant d'ordonnance et qui vous sont
présentés d'abord
reconstruire à l'identique et
juridiquement possible mais si vous
devez
modifier même légèrement pour des
raisons de sécurité ou pour des raisons
de nouvelles exigences environnementales
le bâtiment existant ça n'est plus une
reconstruction à l'identique il faut
donc permettre par la loi que ces
nouveaux impératifs de sécurité ou que
ces nouvelles normes environnementales
puissent être intégrées tout en assumant
le fait qu'il s'agit d'une
reconstruction à l'identique
idem pour le commencement des travaux
préparatoires ne pas attendre que
l'autorisation soit délivrée faire en
sorte que ce commencement puisse
intervenir démolitions terrassement
installations de chantier
alors même que la délivrance est
seulement au cours d'instruction c'est
l'occasion de gagner du temps
accélérer les procédures pour que nous
puissions retrouver les bâtiments ça
n'est pas supprimer ces instructions
mais c'est faire en sorte qu'elle se
tiennent dans un temps restreint plus
court de manière à préserver les
équilibres mais à favoriser cette
reconstruction
ensuite il y a la question pour les
bâtis publics des marchés publics de
travaux
la proposition qui vous sera faite c'est
de déroger aux obligations de publicité
préalable de permettre un usage plus
étendu des marchés de conception
réalisation
avec en ce qui concerne le financement
de ces travaux
rendre possible la mobilisation du Fonds
de compensation de la TVA pour les
collectivités et leurs groupements dès
l'année de son versement
déroger à la règle des 20% minimum de
participation de la collectivité
maître d'oeuvre
et enfin faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de plafond pour que les
intercommunalités notamment puissent
accompagner les collectivités qui sont
en première ligne et qui sont
directement concernées
certains sans doute s'interrogeront sur
l'étendue de ces dérogations
c'est dérogations sont extrêmement
limitées puisqu'elles ne concerne que
les bâtiments
et les équipements publics qui ont été
touchés entre le 27 juin et le 5 juillet
cette base là aura
réellement la possibilité de limiter
les difficultés éventuelles qui
pourraient être présentées ensuite
l'ambition du gouvernement est bien de
faire en sorte que ces promulgations
puissent intervenir dès que possible
mais en prenant néanmoins à la fois le
temps de saisir le Conseil d'État sur
ces diverses mesures et de finaliser
avec l'ensemble des associations des
lieux les quelques trous dans la
raquette qui pourraient subsister enfin
sur la question budgétaire ce texte
n'est pas une occasion d'aller sortir un
chéquier pour
préempter ce que sera le débat demain du
partage de cet effort de reconstruction
et ce pour deux raisons
d'une part parce que le montant
consolidée des dégâts nous ne le
connaissons pas les collectivités ont
jusqu'au 30 septembre pour faire
remonter la liste des dégâts qu'elles
ont connu et les préfets dans la même
période assument l'évaluation de ces
montants ensuite parce que quand nous
connaîtrons ces montants il faudra
commencer par défalquer de ces sommes
les sommes qui sont dues par les
assurances ça n'est qu'à ce moment là
que la question du delta se posera et
que la question de la participation des
émeutiers ou de leurs parents
au fait de rembourser les dégâts qui ont
été causés devra évidemment être mis sur
la table merci à tous et à toutes de
votre attention merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Jean
le président Mattei rapporteur de la
commission des affaires économiques et
pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame le Président
Monsieur le Ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques mes chers
collègues
les violons urbaines qui sont qui se
sont déroulées entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet dernier si elles peuvent nous
interroger sur diverses politiques
publiques posent la question dans
l'urgence de veiller à la continuité et
la stabilité de leur public et du
service public
pour ce faire il nous a paru impératif
de réparer et de remettre en état dans
les plus progrès délais les équipements
publics et les quelques 750 bâtiments
publics et trois fois plus de bâtiments
privés qui ont été abîmés et dégradés au
cours de ces événements
précise et limitée
l'article premier Abily que le
gouvernement apprend par voie
d'ordonnance les mesures propres à
accélérer la reconstruction et la
réflexion des bâtiments dégradés lors de
violence urbaines d'abord pour autoriser
le reconstruction identique ou sous
réserve de modifications limitées et
d'amélioration justifiée même si les
règles d'urbanisme en vigueur si
opposent ensuite pour permettre
l'engagement de travaux préliminaires
des avant la délivrance de
l'autorisation d'urbanisme ou la
décision de non opposition à la
déclaration préalable enfin pour
accélérer en passant par exemple de six
mois à 6 semaines le traitement des
demandes d'autorisation d'urbanisme y
compris en ce qui concerne les
consultations de différentes instances
autorité qui peuvent être impliquées
dans sa délivrance l'article 2 habilite
le gouvernement instauré un régime
dérogatoire à certaines règles de la
commande publique pour les marchés de
travaux sur les bâtiments concernés
c'est des régression permettrait aux
acheteurs publics premièrement de passer
des marchés public sans publicité mais
avec mise en concurrence pour des
travaux dans le montant sur inférieur à
un seuil défini dans l'ordonnance et qui
serait nettement supérieur aux droits
communs qui je vous le rappelle de
100.000 euros deuxièmement il s'agirait
de permettre aux acheteurs publics de ne
pas alertir leur marché dans certains
cas cette faculté pourrait permettre un
gain de plusieurs mois l'article 3
habilite le gouvernement a faciliter le
financement par les collectivités
territoriales des travaux de réparation
et de reconstruction nécessaire il
s'agit il s'agira notamment d'abord de
pouvoir déterminer des modalités
particulières de versement des
instributions destinées bénéficiaires du
Fonds de compensation pour la taxe sur
la valeur ajoutée le fameux FCTVA au
titre des dépenses éligibles un
financement dans ce cadre il s'agit
ainsi de permettre le versement
contemporain du FCTV en année N ensuite
l'article prévoit de déroger aux
exigences de participation minimale des
collectivités territoriale mettre
d'ouvrage au financement de leurs
projets d'investissement pour leur
permettre de bénéficier de subventions
pouvant aller jusqu'à 100% du coût des
travaux ces dispositifs permettront une
véritable facilitation et une
accélération du financement des travaux
contribuant à soulager les collectivités
et leur tension de trésorerie il s'agit
donc là de mesure qui accompagnent
utilement la mise en place du fond de
financement de travaux préparés par la
circulaire de la première ministre
j'estime que ces dispositions sont
nécessaires et proportionnées et je vous
proposerai comme la commission des
Affaires d'économiques qu'à CGR
d'adopter le texte sans modification
bien sûr au-delà du travail de
reconstruction la restauration de nos
quartiers devra vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre devra aussi être mené sur le
long terme et les problématiques de ces
territoires abordés bien plus largement
mais ce projet de loi nous permet
d'aborder
utilement les problèmes les plus urgents
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président nous allons
maintenant entamer la discussion
générale avec Monsieur Thibault Bazin
pour le groupe les républicains et pour
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous voici réunis ce matin en
séance pour examiner le projet de loi
permettant l'accélération de la
reconstruction des bâtiments dégradés ou
démolis au cours des violences urbaines
survenue du 27 juin au 5 juillet 2023
adopté à l'unanimité par le Sénat
avant-hier monsieur le ministre vous
avez retiré à raison un quatrième
article prévu initialement qui aurait
rendu le projet de loi inacceptable ce
quatrième article visant à faciliter les
expropriations dans les copropriétés
dégradées aurait porté une atteinte trop
importante au droit de la propriété
merci d'y avoir renoncé afin de
permettre une adoption de ce projet de
loi les violences urbaines
émeute survenue du 27 juin au 5 juillet
nous ont profondément scandalisé les
dégâts sont énormes leur ampleur est
considérable avec plus de 500 communes
concernées plus de 800 bâtiments
dégradés sans prendre à des dépositaires
de la force publique à des proches des
lus est intolérable j'ai une pensée pour
l'épouse et les enfants de Vincent Jean
Brun mère de L'Haÿ-les-Roses sans
prendre à des commissariats des brigades
de gendarmerie des mairies des
établissements scolaires des
bibliothèques des maisons de quartier
des centres hospitaliers des crèches des
cafés des pharmacies est intolérable les
auteurs doivent être poursuivis et
sanctionnés et je le dis haut et fort
devant la représentation nationale ces
auteurs devront aussi participer au
financement des reconstructions par des
amendes pénales c'est de ces auteurs
devront également y contribuer par des
travaux d'intérêt général et la
responsabilité de leurs parents quand
ils sont mineurs devra aussi être
engager quand cela sera justifié c'est
une question de justice
cela étant dit il nous faut rétablir
dans les meilleurs délais la continuité
des services publics sur l'ensemble d'un
territoire cela passe par la
reconstruction des bâtiments et
équipements publics et il y a urgence
par exemple pour les écoles avec
l'échéance de la prochaine rentrée
scolaire pour construire il faut obtenir
des autorisations passer des marchés et
trouver des financements assurément ce
projet de loi répond à des besoins
d'allègement des procédures de réduction
des délais d'assouplissement des règles
pour bénéficier de financement nous les
soutiendrons car le droit actuel ne
permettrait pas la reconstruction à
l'identique de tous les biens dégradés
ou détruits le droit actuel ne
permettrait pas de sécuriser tous les
donneurs d'ordre pour accélérer les
marchés publics et même si ce projet de
loi ne prévoit pas de financement direct
par l'État à ses reconstructions la
possibilité de bénéficier du
remboursement anticipé du FCVA de cette
année qui pourrait d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre généralisé pour toutes les
collectivités la possibilité de
bénéficier de 100% de subventions et la
possibilité de déplafonner les fonds de
concours des intercommunalités
dans le bon sens pour permettre aux
acteurs publics locaux de trouver des
solutions de financement concernant les
commerces et services telles les cafés
ou pharmacies qui ont été vandalisés il
faudra aussi les accompagner s'ils ne
sont pas couverts totalement par leur
assurance il n'en va de même pour les
communes qui n'ont pas souscrit
d'assurance contre les émeutes
permettez-moi aussi d'évoquer les
particuliers qui ont vu leurs biens
dégrader notamment ceux qui ont vu leur
véhicule partir en fumée j'exhorte les
assurances à trouver des solutions avec
l'État pour les indemniser au mieux avec
des expertises rapides ces victimes ne
doivent pas être abandonnés à leur sort
il demeure la question du financement
par l'état de ses propres bâtiments
dégradés d'ici l'automne un chiffrage
devait être produit il faudra aussi
l'accompagner des mesures de sûreté pour
mieux protéger ses bâtiments d'État tels
que les trésorerie sûrement par le
déploiement de la vidéoprotection alors
que notre pays va connaître une très
grave crise de la construction que des
besoins de reconstruction existent dans
des espaces qui n'ont pas été concernés
par les sais émeutes du 27 juin au 5
juillet il apparaît par ailleurs
nécessaire monsieur le ministre que le
gouvernement engage à la sortie d'été
une réforme structurante de
simplification de l'urbanisme et des
marchés car après les énergies
renouvelables les installations
nucléaires et l'industrie verte il
s'agit déjà du quatrième projet de loi
illustrant la nécessité d'alléger nos
contraintes urbanistiques en l'espace
d'un an ce besoin de l'igier ferrer pour
permettre un traitement accéléré vient
souligner des délais de droit commun
trop long et des procédures de droit
commun trop lourd des complexes ce qui
freine le développement en France les
trois articles dans la version du projet
que nous examinons ce matin consiste en
déshabilitations du gouvernement à
légiférer par ordonnance nous
n'apprécions pas la méthode mais aller
vite et bien sur des sujets techniques
en s'adaptant dans les prochaines
semaines tant à le justifier dans le
contexte actuel l'urgence est indéniable
les trous dans la raquette dans le droit
existant sont indéniables ce sont les
raisons pour lesquelles notre groupe en
responsabilité soutiendra ces
dispositions en espérant à votre
conforme pour autant nous invitons le
gouvernement à présenter ces ordonnances
le moment venu au Parlement pour les
ratifier car la pratique inverse est de
plus en plus observée nous invitons
surtout le gouvernement à les présenter
au plus vite en conseil des ministres si
possible avant la posée estivale pour
l'article 2 afin de ne pas perdre le
temps sans cette gagner par la
disposition dérogatoire contenues dans
cet article cela permet très de passer
les marchés publics au plus vite enfin
ce projet de loi ce bornes à facilité à
reconstruction maternelle ce n'est pas
suffisant pour ne plus revu soit ça il
faut s'atteler aux causes de ces
violences commises contre les symboles
de notre République afin que cela ne se
reproduise plus nous invitons le
gouvernement à engager au plus vite une
restauration de l'autorité à différents
niveaux et apporter une ambition
d'intégration républicaine à même de
partager un destin commun animé par
l'amour de la France Merci monsieur
député
la parole est à Monsieur Thierry Benoît
pour le groupe horizon et apparenté pour
5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre cher Christophe
Béchu cher Christophe
c'est le président de la commission chef
Guillaume sera porteur cher Jean-Paul
mes chers collègues je m'exprime ce
matin donc au nom du groupe horizon et
naturellement les députés du groupe
horizon soutiendront votre proposition
votre projet de loi monsieur le ministre
en souhaitant un adopter conforme par un
souci de rapidité d'exécution et
d'efficacité naturellement le texte qui
nous ramène à une actualité brûlante et
déchirante se passe de grands discours
il se passe de grands mots c'est un
texte de reconstruction
c'est un texte de réparation matériel
qui vise autant que faire ce peu à
permettre à la vie tout simplement
permettre à la vie de reprendre son
cours dans les quartiers qui ont été
l'objet de violence urbaines et des mute
un seul chiffre à titre personnel
m'interpelle et me marque lorsqu'on
imagine que
243 établissements scolaires ont été
dégradés ceci ne peut nous ramener qu'à
La Grave réalité et le niveau de tension
auquel est soumis notre pays depuis un
certain nombre de mois et je dirais même
d’années il s'agit donc de réparer les
écoles les équipements culturels les
équipements sportifs un certain nombre
de services notamment les services de la
petite enfance je prends l'exemple des
crèches mais aussi des bâtiments publics
comme les mairies sans oublier tout
l'arsenal de bâtiments privés de
particulier de commerce qui ont été
dégradés le texte nous permet donc
d'intervenir sur les équipements les
bâtiments et les infrastructures
ce matin nous débattrons nous
interviendrons sur trois sujets trois
domaines le premier point c'est le code
de l'urbanisme puisqu'il s'agit de
reconstruire à l'identique avec les
règles du moment c'est à dire les règles
de 2023 en saisissant au passage les
opportunités possibles pour améliorer
les questions liées à la transition
énergétique celle liée à la sécurité et
naturellement l'accessibilité le
deuxième article nous permettra
d'intervenir sur le code des marchés
publics la question de la publicité qui
n'est pas obligatoire mais naturellement
une mise en concurrence est là on peut
par nature faire confiance aux maires de
nos collectivités locales de nos
communes pour mettre en concurrence et
bien les différents corps de métiers qui
seront sollicités simplification en
matière de délin-destruction des permis
de construire et d'urbanisme nous devons
à cette occasion être des acteurs de la
simplification le troisième sujet sur
lequel nous allons intervenir c'est le
financement avec une trajectoire et un
objectif leur zéro reste à charge pour
les communes naturellement s'adapter à
la question des marchés européens
monsieur le mini j'imagine que dans le
débat vous repréciserez ce que vous avez
fait d'ailleurs déjà en commission la
question du montant des marchés autour
d'un million un million et demi d'euros
pour être dans les règles européennes le
sujet des 80% de subventions qui est la
règle commune qui est connue et là si on
veut un zéro reste à charge et bien il
faut naturellement aller au-delà et
enfin la question du Fonds de
compensation de la TVA que tous les élus
locaux connaissent passer d'une plus
deux à l'immédiateté donc du de la
récupération de la TVA reste ensuite une
fois ce texte voté en effet à identifier
les responsabilités des auteurs de ces
dégradations et autant que faire ce peu
les faire participer sous une forme ou
sous une autre eux leurs parents il y
aura aussi à évaluer le montant total
des dégradations et voir la prise en
charge réelle par les assurances pour
terminer ce qui nous est posé aussi
comme question après cette réparation
matérielle je vais réemployer les mots
que j'ai utilisé en commission c'est la
réparation immatérielle et morale et la
question qui nous est posée en 2023 pour
notre pays la France c'est celle du
vivre ensemble et puis ce que nous
sommes des députés de la nation puisque
nous sommes des députés de la nation et
puisque j'ai la chance de siéger dans
cette émission depuis 2007 depuis de 16
ans je le dis humblement et modestement
mais nous avons nous autres chacun en
tant que député en tant que représentant
de la nation une forme de responsabilité
quant à l'image que l'on donne des
relations humaines et on ne peut pas
passer son temps à chauffer à blanc une
certaine partie des Français et ensuite
s'étonner que dans nos quartiers quel
que soit nos origines quel que soit nos
catégories sociales quel que soit nos
conditions de vie et bien que nous
soyons amenés à ne plus comprendre nous
devons nous parler nous devons pouvoir
vivre ensemble parce que lorsque l'on se
parle raisonnablement et
respectueusement on se comprend et on
construit le vivre ensemble merci
monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Sabrina sebahi
pour le groupe écologiste nupet c'est
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
un mort de plus en mort de trop le jeune
Naël a été tué le 27 juin dernier à
Nanterre par un officier de police lors
d'un contrôle routier suite à un refus
d'obtempérer quelques mois après elle
vous sait Camara tu es dans les mêmes
circonstances en banlieue d'Angoulême
comme en 2005 suite à la mort de ziade
et Bouna quand comme en 2007 à
Villiers-le-Bel comme en 2017 suite à la
mutilation de Théo lors de son
arrestation la colère et les mois se
sont cristallisés dans les violences
bien évidemment nul d'entre nous
n'approuvra ces violences c'est pillages
ces destructions des petits-fils
notamment publique un corps plus nous
tolérerons pas la violence contre les
élus locaux toujours en première ligne
cependant vous ne pouvez trouver comme
seule réponse la matraque pour les
quartiers et le chéquier pour les dégâts
d'année en année de violences en
violence les conséquences sont toujours
été pensées par la sécurité par le
sécurité tandis que les causes elles ont
continué de mûrir et produisent au fil
du temps des fractures de plus en plus
béantes dans notre société 5 millions de
nos concitoyens vivent dans un des 1500
quartiers estampillés politiques de la
ville mes chers collègues où est la
vision d'avenir pour ces quartiers où en
sont les promesses de justice sociale et
d'égalité républicaine dans ces
quartiers 40% de la population est en
situation de pauvreté 45% des jeunes
chômage il y a deux fois moins de
professionnels de santé par habitant que
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
moins de bureau de poste de maison de
justice ou encore de transport à cet
abandon des populations s'ajoutent à un
abandon des municipalités à quand date
le dernier budget ambitieux de soutien
aux collectivités territoriales cette
année encore on nous présage un projet
de loi finance qui annonce fièrement une
augmentation d'un milliard pour la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
carburant financier de l'État ou
municipalité mais ce milliard ne viendra
même pas rattraper la moitié de
l'inflation et des baisses systématiques
de la DGF en réalité à nouveau cette
année cette dotation sera en baisse et
elle se traduira concrètement dans nos
villes dans nos quartiers par mois
d'activités culturelles l'arrêt des
subventions municipales des équipements
sportifs fermés des réductions
d'effectifs la DGS
merci c'est celle qui donne les outils
au maire de penser les lacunes de l'État
pour que chacun qu'il habite le 15e
arrond issement la cité des pabloins
Nanterre ou de l'Ariana Nice puisse se
sentir égal lié par un destin commun
pour que chacun puisse s'émanciper
travailler sur une même base d'égalité
vivre à égalité bien évidemment
l'urgence est de reconstruire et de
reconstruire vite c'est une demande des
élus locaux et c'est un devoir que de
leur répondre
nos écoles
seul madame c'est Baye à la parole s'il
vous plaît
nos écoles nos mairies nos commissariats
nos commerces de proximité nos centres
sociaux doivent être opérationnels au
plus vite pour que les habitants
puissent en bénéficier au plus tôt oui
c'est dégradations ce sont déroulés dans
des quartiers où les habitants ont le
plus besoin et c'est en cela que nous
écologistes voterons ce texte mais ne
remettons pas un simple coup de ciment
par ici de simple brille par là nous
devons revoir les fondations même de
notre République au sein de nos
quartiers au sein de nos banlieues je
voudrais le redire ici la solution ne
réside pas uniquement dans le logement
créé par exemple des NPN RRU bras armées
de la politique de la ville sans
l'accord des habitants parfois même
contre eux sans accompagnement social
sans refondation complète des politiques
dans ces quartiers ne recollera pas les
morceaux enfin reconstruire c'est une
opportunité de faire mieux l'état
énergétique du parc public comme privé
ne répond pas aux normes
environnementales et énergétiques les
plus performantes dans des tours où
l'été est un four et l'hiver un
congélateur il faut s'attaquer à la
rénovation énergétique dans les services
publics inaccessibles ou les personne en
situation de handicap lutte parfois pour
franchir les bureaux d'un bureau de
poste il nous faut s'attaquer au
chantier de l'accessibilité dans des
quartiers ou seul un bus transit une
fois par heure il faut s'attaquer au
chantier de la mobilité dans une France
qui n'a jamais été aussi antagoniste en
proie au chimères sécurité et
discriminant de l'extrême droite
investissant massivement dans
l'éducation dans l'emploi dans la
culture dans l'insertion en somme
investissons dans l'émancipation
véritablement pour que pour que le
prochain mort ne soit pas celui de trop
qui mènera à des drames encore plus
tragiques
je vois que ça vous et moi mais en
réalité vous devriez effectivement vous
devriez effectivement vous poser la
question de ce qui s'est passé parce que
ce qui s'est passé n'est pas anodin en
réalité je vous le dis ce n'est pas
anodin
et en réalité votre comportement montre
que vous n'avez rien compris de ce qui
s'est passé ces dernières semaines
[Applaudissements]
vous feriez mieux d'écouter ce qui s'est
passé de comprendre aussi le message qui
a été donné
de comprendre ce message pour pouvoir
justement réparer la société française
et ne pas laisser les choses continuer
de cette manière je vous remercie merci
madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Hubert vulfran
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicain UPS c'est pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur chaque collègue
les mesures présentées en urgence ce
matin dans le cadre de ce texte sur la
reconstruction des bâtiments dégradés ou
des momies du 27 juin ou 5 juillet sont
bien évidemment très attendus par les
élus locaux et l'ensemble des
administrés qui sont concernés cette
disposition notre groupe les considère
donc comme strictement nécessaire
strictement nécessaire la reconstruction
qui ouvre la possibilité d'améliorer les
conditions d'accueil qualité
environnementale et la sécurité des
lieux qui abritent ces services publics
de proximité strictement nécessaire
l'accélération et la simplification des
procédures permet de réaliser ces
travaux le plus rapidement possible
strictement nécessaire les dispositions
particulières permettant aux
collectivités territoriales de disposer
de subventions
[Musique]
mon collègue les reconstructions donc
voilà nous sommes devant évidemment
l'ensemble de ces élus de ces
populations et qui s'interrogent sur
l'avenir immédiat et long terme des
services de leur population et de leur
budget de tout simplement de leur budget
avec la possibilité de satisfaire ou non
rapidement aux besoins quotidiens des
habitants nous estimons que ce texte
répond encore que très partiellement
bien évidemment à ces interrogations
dans une séquence longue
particulièrement délicate pour les
collectivités locales en particulier
pour les communes populaires la question
des dotations en particulier de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement est à
nouveau légitimement reposer et la
proposition de notre groupe qui a été
porté par Jean-Marc Tellier récemment
sur l'indexation de la DGF en version
n'en prend que plus de relief plus
fondamentalement réparer les bâtiments
qui hébergent les services publics de
proximité
nous les avons tous cités nous les avons
en mémoire ce n'est pas réparer le
service public vous êtes bien évidemment
très c'est très sévèrement attendu sur
ce point alors que nous le disons en
constance vous n'avez cessé de dégrader
ces services publics en adoptant une
logique de rigueur et d'attrition à leur
égard budget après budget nous nous
retrouverons bien sûr sur ces bancs à la
prochaine rentrée
parallèlement sur ce texte nous tenons à
déplorer l'absence de toute mesure
concernant le secteur assurantiel or il
est à nos yeux absolument nécessaire de
mettre à contribution et responsabiliser
les compagnies d'assurance afin de
garantir la réparation intégrale des
dommages subis par les particuliers des
associations les organismes de logement
notamment aujourd'hui la loi pose pour
principe que les assureurs n'ont pas à
répondre des pertes et dommages
occasionner je cite le code par les
émeutes ou par les mouvements populaires
nous avions déposé un amendement visant
à rendre obligatoire la couverture
intégrale de ces risques et un autre
amendement proposé la mise en place
d'une contribution exceptionnelle des
compagnies d'assurance afin d'alimenter
un fond destiné à indemniser les
particuliers et les associations
victimes de dégradation nous regrettons
très profondément que nous amendements
étaient déclarés il recevable pour
conclure
comme je le disais ce texte est
particulièrement attendu par les élus
locaux il devra être suivi très
rapidement en particulier lors de nos
débats budgétaires prochains de
l'automne d'autres dispositions
strictement financières selon nous
au-delà bien aisément nous allons devoir
bien sûr vous donnons demander à nouveau
des comptes sur votre politique nous y
reviendrons
ce n'est pas le lieu nous conclurons
dans le strict cadre du débat qui
s'inscrit dans ces derniers jours de
notre session par un vote que nous
voulons efficace et sobre nous voterons
ce texte merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Benjamin
sainte-huile pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire et
pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
toutes les colères aussi légitimes mais
partagée soit-elle ne pourront jamais
justifier les violences aveugles et
sourdes qui ont été perpétrés partout
sur notre territoire national il y a
maintenant quelques semaines
l'émotion qui s'est emparée du pays
après la mort de ce jeune homme à
Nanterre Naël
est elle tout aussi légitime elle
interroge et le travail d'enquête et de
la justice permettra de faire la lumière
sur les conditions qui ont amené à cette
situation
inacceptable
néanmoins aujourd'hui le temps n'est pas
venu fort heureusement de retrouver le
concours des petites phrases des
déclarations faciles de la caricature
nous savons nous qui sommes en prise
avec la réalité du quotidien pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous qui avons
administré des communes nous connaissons
le choc qu'a représenté pour nos
concitoyens de voir disparaître dans ces
moments de violence des lieux
d'apprentissage de culture ces lieux qui
portent la République qui font sens et
qui caractérise le vivre ensemble
nous ne pouvons pas accepter un seul
instant une seule seconde que soit
remise en cause la capacité pour toutes
et tous dans ce pays de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur un service public fort qui
accompagne tous les citoyens de France
qu'ils soient les plus fragiles les plus
éloignés des services du quotidien ou
ceux qui vivent dans les territoires où
le service est à proximité nous avons
été profondément marqués profondément
meurtri par ces moments qui viennent
soustraire à nos populations ce bien que
certains n'ont peu que trop peu celui de
la capacité à vivre ensemble à travers
les outils de la République ceux qui
sont portés par l'État lui-même ceux qui
sont portés par les collectivités notre
pays devra légitimement s'interroger sur
les réponses qui doivent être apportées
à cet épisode si violent que nous avons
connu
mais nous devons considérer une fois
encore que dans un pays comme le nôtre
avec pour seul boussole la République et
l'intérêt général il n'est plus
acceptable de voir nos forces de
sécurité
sans cesse remise en cause de manière
systémique nous ne pouvons plus accepter
de voir nos sapeurs-pompiers en
intervention être caillassées dans un
certain nombre de parcelles de la
République en disant cela nous ne disons
pas que la seule réponse justifie
exclusivement la réponse de l'ordre nous
savons nous qui sommes en prises avec
les populations que c'est une réponse
globale complexe qui doit être
construite et qui doit s'appuyer
évidemment sur la capacité à accompagner
les populations répondre à une politique
que certains considèreront de trop
social celle qui accompagne les
populations qui espèrent voir leurs
enfants vivre au mieux que ce qu'ils ne
vivent eux-mêmes dans des quartiers ou
parfois la question de la discrimination
plus assez posées dans ces quartiers où
parfois l'origine la couleur de peau ou
le prénom peut-être un prétexte à quelle
interrogation de vivre ensemble ce
temps-là viendra et j'espère sans avoir
trop d'espoir que ce débat pourra se
tenir sans trop de facilité de
caricatures au-delà de cela nous nous
retrouvons aujourd'hui pour tenter
d'apporter une réponse immédiate à la
question de la reconstruction celle qui
fait sens pour tout le monde celle qui
permet à nos élus locaux de construire
la République qui avance celle qui
répond vite et fort à ses émeutes
inacceptables celle qui permettront aux
enfants d'ici et d'ailleurs de pouvoir
être scolarisé dans de bonnes conditions
celle qui permettront à la culture de
pouvoir être une des réponses à
l'émancipation et à la capacité encore
une fois à construire des chemins pour
notre jeunesse je le dis avec beaucoup
de sincérité ce texte il est utile
nécessaire et il est vous l'avez dit et
monsieur le ministre tu le rapporteur la
suite logique des discussions qui ont eu
lieu entre les élus locaux l'Association
des maires de France et le président de
la République bien sûr qu'il y aurait
des choses à discuter et améliorer et
nous serons tentés de le faire dans un
pas de temps qui sera réduit mais l'idée
qui doit nous conduire à ce stade c'est
la capacité à permettre effectivement
d'être dans une situation de
reconstruction rapide il y a des
procédures d'urgence qui sont proposées
par ce texte nous les voterons
naturellement en vérifiant ensemble que
nous ne prenons pas des directions qui
construisent une forme de biais qui
permettrait à certaines entreprises par
exemple trop grandes d'exclure des TPE
ou des PME ça fera partie des rares
sujets sur lesquels la discussion se
fera un jour pour le reste vous pouvez
compter sur la solidarité du groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole était
monsieur Robin Reda pour le groupe
Renaissance et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues au nom du groupe Renaissance
je voudrais débuter mon propos par un
hommage au maire aux élus locaux mais
aussi aux forces de police de
gendarmerie aux pompiers aux agents
techniques de nos municipalités qui ont
encourageusement fait face aux Nuits de
violence fin juin début août début
juillet nos mères et en particulier les
maires des plus de 500 communes frappées
par des déchaînements haineux ont
assisté médusé attristé et souvent même
en colère à la dégradation ou à la
destruction de projets qu'ils avaient
mis du temps à imaginer à défendre à
financer et à construire
ils ont assisté au pillage de commerce
de proximité qui font l'âme et du tissu
de nos centres villes et j'ai une pensée
ici plus particulière pour les communes
de la région Île-de-France de mon
département de l'Essonne et de matières
conscription qui ont été douloureusement
affectés après ces émeutes
traumatisantes deux positions
irréconciliables en tout de suite
émerger dans le débat public il y a ceux
qui voudraient tout excuser tout laisser
passer et puis il y a ceux qui
voudraient tout laisser tomber il y a
ceux qui au fond auraient bien voulu que
les émeutes continuent même s'il
préférait ouvertement qu'on s'en prenne
à des bijouteries plutôt qu'à des
bibliothèques il y a ceux qui auraient
bien voulu que la réponse de l'État ne
soit pas à la hauteur pour faire leur
beurre d'une impuissance supposée l'État
a été au rendez-vous police gendarmerie
justice le volontarisme de notre état
régalien a démontré son efficacité pour
mettre fin à un embrasement que rien ne
pouvait justifier ni excuser
quel que soit les émotions qui peuvent
nous saisir dans l'actualité elles ne
peuvent justifier ni les intimidations
ni les exactions nous voulons dire aux
habitants des villes des quartiers ou
des vitres sont brisées des locaux de
service public brûlés que personne ici
ne les abandonnera nous avons résolument
choisi notre camp nous sommes aux côtés
de ceux qui s'engagent pas aux côtés de
ceux qui saccagent et j'espère que nous
serons unanimes sur ce point à l'issue
de nos débats
le projet de loi que nous allons
examiner apporte une réponse rapide aux
élus de nos collectivités désemparés
face aux réinvestissements qui les
attendent la simplification que nous
proposons doit être une invitation à ne
pas baisser les bras l'urgence c'est de
faire flotter à nouveau le drapeau
tricolore partout dans nos centres
villes et dans nos quartiers c'est de
montrer sans délai que la République ne
se laisse pas impressionner nous nous
engageons pour dire que la République
sera toujours plus forte que les
attaques qui tentent de l'affaiblir mes
chers collègues nous sommes pas ici pour
rendre la justice même si comme tous les
Français nous sommes nombreux à espérer
des sanctions effectives pour tous ceux
qui ont été identifiés parmi les
casseurs des nuits de juillet oui ceux
qui ont cassé doivent payer mais ceux
qui n'ont rien demandé ont aussi le
droit de ne pas être les oubliés de la
faire
et nos collectivités nos territoires
monsieur le ministre l'a rappelé hier
lors de notre examen en commission
auront les moyens juridiques et
financiers de reconstruire nous ne
sommes pas la majorité qui a baissé les
dotations collectivités territoriales
nous ne sommes pas la majorité qui a
réduit le périmètre des quartiers
politiques de la ville privant des
centaines d'habitants de moyens nous ne
sommes pas la majorité qui construit
davantage dans des quartiers qui
comptent déjà trop de logements sociaux
nous sommes la majorité de l'équilibre
des territoires alors certes le temps de
l'analyse des causes viendra mais nous
en connaissons au moins une nous savons
qu'il faut que chacun se reconnaisse
comme faisant partie d'une même nation
nous devons repenser la manière de nous
réunir autour de ce qu'est français une
nation c'est une symbolique des idées
qui nous font tenir ensemble et mener un
projet commun mais ce projet commun de
nation il commence tout en bas la nation
elle se construit d'abord autour des
quatre murs d'une mairie
ou d'une maison des associations nous
sommes ici pour dire à la majorité
silencieuse de nos concitoyens de ne pas
se désespérer
disons à la majorité silencieuse de nos
concitoyens de ne pas se désespérer
notre majorité ne se résignera jamais
rien ne justifie la violence la culture
de l'excuse n'est pas un programme mais
rien ne justifie non plus de priver nos
enfants de retrouver leur salle de
classe à l'école à la rentrée de priver
nos policiers des locaux d'intervention
de laisser des gens aux portes explosées
d'un bureau de poste d'empêcher les
habitants de faire du sport ou de
s'épanouir par la culture dans le sillon
sage tracé par le Sénat nous espérons
pouvoir voter rapidement monsieur le
ministre cette habilitation a vous
permettre d'agir vite et d'agir
efficacement je vous remercie merci
Monsieur d'écouter
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine
Villedieu pour le groupe rassemblement
national et pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le ministre il existe bien des
références historiques au 100 jours
annoncés par Emmanuel Macron
malheureusement en 2023 l'histoire ne
retiendra de ses 100 jours qu'une vaste
supercherie emprunte au chaos et à
l'embrasement
huit jours d'émeutes contre 20 en 2005
et pourtant le bilan se veut bien plus
lourd aujourd'hui j'ai une pensée pour
nos policiers nos gendarmes nos
sapeurs-pompiers qui au milieu des
affrontements ont su assurer leur
mission nos commerçants quant à eux
assistaient impuissant au pillage et
osakage de leur boutique les habitants
des quartiers voyaient les flamants
portaient leur véhicule pendant que des
passants étaient pris à partie sans
raison par des meutes de sauvages qui
étaient aux commandes à ce moment-là
Emmanuel Macron
non certainement pas il était un concert
et visiblement quand le chat n'est pas
là les souris patauges
ce sera huit jours de destruction pour
100 jours d'abandon voilà ce que
retiennent rond les Français
nous allons donc débattre de votre
projet de loi pour faciliter la
reconstruction des bâtiments détruit
leur des émeutes et pourtant à la
lecture de votre texte on constate que
vous restez timide pour nommer les
casseurs non il s'agit pas d'une
catastrophe naturelle dans les causes
seraient exogènes les responsables nous
les connaissons principalement des jeux
issus des banlieues rassemblés pour en
découdre et tout détruire adoubé par les
élus de la gauche nupes car oui chers
collègues vous avez une responsabilité
dans ce chaos vous avez refusé d'appeler
au calme vous avez constamment jeté de
l'huile sur le feu certainement aveuglé
par votre éternel fantasme de voir
s'effondrer nos institutions
et pendant ce temps notre gouvernement
tremble
incapable de rétablir l'ordre dans nos
rues selon certains observateurs de
terrain ce serait même l'intervention de
narcotrafiquant qui aurait pu
permis à retour au calme heureusement
les Français l'ont compris elle exprime
ouvertement seul Marine Le Pen aura le
courage de faire face à une violence
devenue endémique
finalement c'est sans surprise votre
texte
prévoit de faire payer la France qui
travaille celle qui ne fait pas de bruit
et qui ne casse pas ce sera donc la
double peine à travers les impôts les
cotisations d'assurance qui augmenteront
la racaille détruit elle est française
dans ce projet de loi vous traitez les
effets sans jamais vous attaquer aux
causes effacer au plus vite les
stigmates des émeutes et faire oublier
aux Français votre incapacité à agir
dans leur intérêt la voilà la vérité les
responsables et les causes ne peuvent
être ignorées ce sont ceux qui noyissent
galvaniser et nourri par un sentiment de
toute-puissance et d'impunité ils
habitent ces zones de non-frances et
emprunte le chemin de la sécession ce
sont 40 années de politiques migratoires
anarchiques associées à des réponses
pénales inadaptées à l'absence
d'exécution des peines la culture de
l'excuse et la repentance permanente
pousse notre pays à une inversion des
valeurs les coupables deviennent des
victimes et les victimes deviennent des
coupables nous devons être impitoyables
face à ceux qui cultivent la haine
anti-France attaque nos symboles et
profane nos mémorielles
c'est aux émeutiers d'assumer l'entière
responsabilité de leur acte sur le plan
pénal civil et doivent payer
l'intégralité des dommages qu'ils ont
causés
et ce à perpétuité s'il le faut comme la
rappeler marine le Penhir lors de la
conférence de presse nous avons des
solutions monsieur le ministre il vous
suffit de les appliquer le principe du
cas sur payeur doit devenir la règle les
émeti étrangers doivent être expulsés
suppression des allocations familiales
pour les familles de délinquants mineurs
abaissement de la majorité pénale à 16
ans pour finir ce texte restera qu'un
pansement sur une jambe de bois les
Français une fois encore perron 40
années de l'acheter politique de
clientélisme et d'aveuglement
idéologique des républicains à la
nupaise en passant par le centre vous
êtes tous complices de cette situation
monsieur le ministre sachez que nous
députés du rassemblement national nous
n'aurons jamais les mains qui tremblent
face à la racaille nous le disons aux
Français lorsque nous serons pouvoir
nous rétablirons l'ordre et nous
rendrons la France à la
avance merci merci monsieur le député
bonjour à tous pour le groupe de la
France insoumise madame Raquel Garrido
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
est-ce que grâce à cette loi l'école
maternelle de La Verrière dans les
Yvelines sera reconstruite avant la
rentrée de septembre
est-ce que grâce à cette loi l'antenne
de police de Bagnolet chez moi en 500
Denis sera reconstruit rapidement est-ce
que grâce à cette loi nous avons la
garantie que tous les bâtiments destinés
à un service public seront reconstruits
rapidement et même reconstruit tout
court la réponse est NON et vous le
savez
pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il n'y a pas de
garantie de financement les collègues de
l'extrême droite laissaient au moins les
autres intervenir je vais gérer ça
[Applaudissements]
laissez on parle des mairies ça nous
intéresse pas mais nous ça nous
intéresse
pas les
mairies et ses bâtiments
et bien que nous ayons pas
d'informations précises là-dessus votre
ministère estime que presque une
collectivité sur deux n'est pas assurée
est-ce que cette loi débloque de
nouveaux crédits en urgence pour
répondre aux besoins de reconstruction
non une circulaire du 7 juillet de la
première ministre dit à l'inverse qu'il
faut aller chercher dans d'autres fonds
existants que vous avez estimé environ
94 millions d'euros qui du coup ne
seront plus disponibles pour les
politiques publiques pour lesquelles ils
avaient été initialement prévus avec un
budget limité et imprévisible les
collectivités devront faire le cas
échéant des choix qu'est-ce qui sera
privilégié la cantine de l'école la
bibliothèque ce dilemme n'est pas
acceptable votre rôle c'est de garantir
que tout sera reconstruit
pour avoir l'assurance que les travaux
d'Emma au plus vite il faudrait un
engagement financier nouveau dans
l'exercice 2023 vous devez donc vous
engager inclure ces nouveaux fonds dans
une loi de finances rectificative à
l'automne vous avez bien porté la
retraite à 64 ans par une loi budgétaire
rectificative vous pouvez bien le faire
pour la reconstruction et pitié ne me
dites pas que le paiement en avance du
fond de compensation de la TVA ou la
suppression de l'obligation de
participation minimale des collectivités
et qui vont un principe de reste à
charge Zéro pour ses collectivités c'est
totalement faux le fond TVA c'est de
l'argent qui appartenait déjà au mairie
même s'il est payé en avance ça ne
change rien et si une connectivité n'est
plus obligée d'apporter un concours le
problème reste entier de qui financera
les 100% restants
mais le pire n'est pas que vous traitiez
mal la question matérielle le pire c'est
que vous traitiez mal la question
immatérielle c'est la première fois
collègue que nous sommes réunis pour
parler de la réplique à la mort à
l'homicide volontaire de Naël le 27 juin
dernier
mais vous n'en parlez pas dans la loi
comme si vous vouliez effacer ce fait de
nos mémoires
le président lui-même en a toujours pas
parlé
votre loi concerne bien les biens
détruits ou dégradés à partir du 27 juin
jour de Naël mais on ne parlant que de
la réplique vous omettez de traiter les
problèmes qui ont été révélés par le
missile involontaire le missile
volontaire homicide volontaire
c'est-à-dire meurtre je ne m'arrange pas
le droit de préjugés un homme présumé
innocent mais c'est la qualification
juridique retenue par la suite s'il vous
plaît
il y aura un procès
et ce policier plaidera qu'il a utilisé
son arme dans le cadre de la loi 2017
qu'attendez-vous pour abroger l'article
435-1 quatrièmement du code de la
sécurité intérieure qu'il y ait
davantage de morts 13 morts en 2022 ça
ne suffit pas la mort le meurtre comme
le qualifie pour le moment la justice de
Naël ne suffit pas et quand traiter vous
la question du racisme dans la police
c'est cela qui construit la paix notre
rôle à tous c'est de construire la paix
il y a une petite musique de la guerre
civile ne l'entendez-vous pas il faut
répondre
je vous le dis collègue je vous le dis
collègue chers collègues il est 10h du
matin donc c'est un peu tôt pour tout ce
brouhaha seul madame Garrido à la parole
et elle termine son propos elle a encore
40 secondes
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas né en France je suis
arrivé en France à l'âge de 14 ans je
suis devenu française à l'âge de 25 ans
je n'accepterai jamais que vous fassiez
le tri entre Français en fonction de
notre ascendance ou de notre religion
je n'ai pas de pays de rechange vous
n'avez pas de pays de rechange vous ne
vous débarrasserez pas de moi ni des
autres
protégeons ce pays protégeons la
République protégeons la justice et la
paix c'est cela notre devoir à tous
[Applaudissements]
bien
dans un calme revenu s'il vous plaît
chers collègues
nous allons écouter pendant 5 minutes
pour le groupe socialiste monsieur et
shanise
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues le 27 juin dernier un jeune
garçon de Nanterre Naël mezzrouk était
abattu par un policier à l'occasion d'un
contrôle routier la nouvelle victime
d'une terrible série qui pose la
question des conditions de l'usage de
leurs armes par les forces de l'ordre et
plus largement de notre doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre et du rapport police
population comme vous l'appelez comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
ce n'est pas l'objet de notre discussion
d'aujourd'hui la justice doit suivre son
cours et le Parlement doit jouer son
rôle de contrôle à cet égard notre
groupe a sollicité et obtenu une
évaluation de la loi de 2017 relative à
la sécurité publique ou mon collègue
Roger Vico sera co-rapporteur
d'opposition ce qui nous rassemble ce
matin c'est l'enjeu de reconstruction en
effet ce drame a déclenché une flambée
de violence entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet initialement alimenté par une
réponse judiciaire perçue comme
complaisante alors une vidéo des faits
contredisaient les premiers éléments
recueillis auprès des policiers ces
violences que nous condamnons à nouveau
sans réserve en prix une ampleur inédite
depuis celle de 2005 consécutive à la
mort de Zied Bena et Bouna Traoré des
mairies des commissariats des écoles des
crèches ou encore des médiathèques ont
été détruites privées nos concitoyens de
l'accès à certains services publics
souvent dans les territoires où ceci
sont des gens si peu présents des
commerces des locaux d'artisans au
bureau ont également eu à subir des
dégradations et destructions tout comme
des véhicules privés au détriment de
ceux qui parfois doivent se lever tôt
pour aller travailler il est de notre
responsabilité de leur apporter une
réponse rapide en cela ce projet de loi
est bienvenu et nous le soutiendrons
je souhaite cependant commencer comme je
l'ai fait en commission parce que par
ceux qui n'est pas dans ce texte mais
qu'il faut traiter urgemment tout
d'abord la question des assurances nous
voulons reconstruire vite et pour notre
part reconstruire bien mais entre les
expertises contre expertise ou
négociation en vue de protocoles
transactionnels des mois voire des
années sont parfois perdus toutes les
collectivités ne pourront reconstruire
sans avoir d'abord une compensation par
leurs assureurs si elles ne sont pas
nécessairement dans le périmètre du
texte il faudra monsieur le ministre que
le gouvernement amène les assureurs à
prendre toute leur part et rapidement
nous gardons à l'esprit leur mauvaise
volonté initiale au début de la pandémie
du covid-19 le second sujet connexe du
premier c'est bien entendu la question
des moyens et aide financières si ce
texte facilite des taux élevés de
cofinancement faut-il encore que les
crédits existent et soit rapidement
mobilisés nous avons besoin d'une réelle
visibilité en la matière et que ces
moyens ne soient pas uniquement un
recyclage de crédit de dotation de
soutien à l'investissement
s'agissant des dispositions proposées
dans les ordonnances elles-mêmes nous
vous inviterons monsieur le ministre à
prendre certains engagements aux banques
par nos amendements afin que des
intentions partagées trouve une
traduction concrète vous avez d'ores et
déjà apporté certaines garanties en
commission comme sur les bailleurs
sociaux et je n'y reviendrai pas
notamment essentiel pour notre groupe
que les reconstructions à identiques se
fassent tout en respectant les
réglementations thermiques
d'accessibilité ou de sécurité les plus
récentes voir les plus élevés il nous
semble également essentiel d'assurer une
juste conciliation s'agissant de la
commande publique entre la volonté
d'aller vite la préservation du denier
public et la prévention des risques de
corruption nous formulerons par
amendement une proposition simple
permettant un meilleur contrôle
démocratique sans apporter aux athètes
objectives aux objectifs poursuivis
monsieur le ministre je ne doute pas que
vous saurez nous rassurer sur ces
questions et qui vous prendrez les
engagements nécessaires au cours de nos
débats enfin nous le répétons et nous le
répéterons reconstruire monsieur ne
suffira pas pour apaiser les fractures
de nos sociétés et répandre aux enjeux
d'urgence sociale il est urgent d'agir
et d'agir bien je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
démocrate Monsieur Philippe Vigier
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission cher Guillaume Caden
cher rapporteur cher Jean-Paul Mathis
président du groupe démocrate chers
collègues
ces images auxquelles nous avons pu
assister tous entre le 27 juin et le 5
juillet sont des images dramatiques
c'est celle d'une république fragilisée
d'une république
qui a été déstabilisée pendant des
longues journées et d'abord moi je
voudrais naturellement avoir une pensée
pour la famille de ce jeune qui est mort
mais également avoir une pensée émue
pour toutes ces forces de l'ordre tous
ceux qui n'ont jamais lâché jour et nuit
pour faire en sorte que la paix revienne
et que le calme revienne et que l'on
soit en capacité d'avancer comme l'a dit
le ministre
le moment de l'analyse
le moment des enquêtes judiciaires
l'analyse de la politique de la ville et
je vous en dirai un mot parce que j'ai
en partage avec Thierry Benoît le fait
d'être là depuis quelques années
dommage les députés écologistes ne sont
pas là mais je le dirai à la fin de mon
propos il faudra aussi savoir pourquoi
en mettant plus d'argent comme nous le
faisons depuis de longues années
monsieur le ministre et bien les
résultats ne soient pas à la hauteur et
moi je n'oublie pas que ces images que
nous avons tous vu elles ont touché 500
communes que ces images elles ont
abîmées détruits 750 bâtiments publics
ou privés et ayons aussi une pensée émue
pour ceux qui ont perdu leur outil de
travail pour le médecin généraliste dans
le cabinet a été brûlé pour l'infirmière
qui n'a plus de voiture pour les
enseignants qui n'ont plus d'école
pour ce car qui a été brûlé ce bus
sanitaire dans lesquels on dépisté des
pathologies en particulier pour les
femmes toutes ces images c'est une
France défigurée et il faut monsieur le
ministre essayer tout votre honneur de
porter ce texte de le porter dans
l'urgence être en capacité naturellement
d'essayer de gommer les stigmates vous
avez fait le bon choix avec le
rapporteur parce que
avec Jean-Paul Mattei en matière
d'urbanisme de logement du construction
vous avez un orfèvre matière et je suis
persuadé que toutes les facilitations
après la prolongation des ordonnances il
vous les apportera
est-ce que nous sommes en train de faire
c'est un signal qu'on envoie au pays
est-ce que oui non lorsqu'il y a une
crise comme celle-là on est capable de
réagir rapidement ce que oui ou non là
où il y a lenteur
ceux qui sont maires qui l'ont été
savent que entre le moment où on dessine
un projet et au moment où on ouvre une
école il se passe trois ans C'est ça la
vraie vie de tous les jours le moment où
on réhabilite un commerce et qu'il est
public il se passe souvent plusieurs
mois et là le fait de au travers des
trois articles monsieur le ministre pour
la reconstruction des règles d'urbanisme
qui sont assouplies avec d'ailleurs une
garantie naturellement que on construira
avec des normes qui sont sur le plan
énergétique bien plus performantes que
nous avons auparavant tout ce que nous
allons faire sur les financements on a
mégarido vous hier en commission vous
étiez ému parce qu'il y a pas d'argent
nouveau d'abord je permet de vous
rappeler une chose lorsque vous
récupérez la TVA immédiatement ça vous
évite une trésorerie vous voyez plutôt
que d'attendre pendant deux ans ça c'est
déjà de l'argent public quand vous aurez
gérer une collectivité vous verrez que
ça se passe comme ça et vous dire aussi
que la fongibilité des aides de l'État
c'est quelque chose d'exceptionnel qui
touchera le monde rural comme le monde
urbain c'est pour ça que je me suis
élevé en commission contre des
amendements où on voulait simplement
réserver de la fameuse 2/3 donc ce que
nous faisons sur les marchés publics où
on ne foule pas aux pieds le contrôle de
l'égalité madame Garrido bien au
contraire
il sera toujours là au final mais
faciliter les la loi la lotissement
faciliter la mobilisation de ces marchés
jusqu'à une somme dont vous parlerez
monsieur le ministre j'imagine un
million et demi d'euros fait que nous
apporterons une réponse très forte donc
ce texte et il faut le voter conforme
avec les sénateurs d'une manière qu'on
soit opérationnelle le plus rapidement
possible et j'imagine que vous aurez à
coeur que cette ordonnance sorte le plus
vite possible c'est une réponse qu'une
venons à la France assez mère que nous
vénérons tous les uns et les autres donc
on sait très bien que ce sont les
piliers de la République et bien ces
piliers ils doivent être confortés car
les Français nous regardent alors j'ai
été assez indigné car j'ai vu l'attitude
du rassemblement national qui est d'un
renoncement permanent ne pas voter un
tel texte je vous le dis ne pas voter à
tel texte parce que
parce que vous vous reconnaisses parce
que vous vouliez des mots requalifiant
ces violences urbaines la France saura
que vous n'avez pas voulu reconstruire
on va pas attendre quatre années pour
reconstruire il faut reconstruire
maintenant c'est votre responsabilité et
on leur dira
quand à la nups et aux écologistes c'est
dommage que Madame Chatelain ne soit pas
là moi j'étais député lorsqu'un
gouvernement de gauche a baissé de 13
milliards et demi d'euros au lieu de
dotations aux collectivités 13 milliards
et demi d'euros avec une politique de la
ville qui s'est effondré de 40%, mais
quel kilos quelle honte
et bien vous devriez au moins au moins
au moins quand on sait la mobilisation
les plans de relance je crois que vous
avez une activité non été autant aider
merci
[Applaudissements]
et dans un hémicycle apaisé pour
accueillir nos visiteurs nous allons
écouter 5 minutes Emmanuel Ménard
ce Minos c'est pas parce que c'est votre
anniversaire que vous devez la ramener
matin midi et soir
[Musique]
allez-y madame
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
23878 feux sur la voie publique
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendie ou dégradés dont
273 postes de police 105 mairies
incendiées ou dégradées 168 écoles
attaquées 17 élus menacés ou agressés et
au total
355 personnes interpellées et c'est
heureux plus d'un millier condamné face
à ce déchaînement de haine c'est la
stupéfaction puis très vite la peur et
la colère rien ne peut justifier les
violences qui ont enflammé notre pays
elles sont insupportables inacceptables
impardonnable elles ne sont que
prétextes et récupération elle ne vise
en aucun cas à exprimer une émotion
légitime mais bien à fouler au pied nos
institutions et à détruire tout ce qui
les incarne disons-le franchement nos
émeutiers se contrefoutent de la mort de
Naël à la Devèze à Béziers une
cinquantaine de voyous ont dévasté leur
propre quartier ou plus de 150 millions
d'euros ont été investis pour le
bien-être de ces quatre mille habitants
ils ont gravement détérioré la Mission
Locale d'Insertion faite pour eux la
mairie annexe a été saccagé des
véhicules ont été brûlés la maison de
quartier celle qui accueille leur petit
frère ou leur petite sœur pour les
centres de loisirs qui du coup sont
privés de vacances cet été a été
incendié dans un autre quartier c'est la
poste et divers commerces qui ont subi
des dégâts considérables les policiers
nationaux et municipaux les gendarmes et
les pompiers ont malgré les attaques et
les jeux de projectiles fait preuve d'un
sang-froid à toute épreuve l'enveloppe
de remise en état sera lourde dans ma
ville la première estimation avoisine le
million d'euros pour les seuls bâtiments
publics
qui va payer les français bien sûr ils
devront payer la note d'une façon ou
d'une autre ce qui est terriblement
injuste pour les rassurer le chef de
l'État a promis une loi d'urgence c'est
la même que nous étudions ce matin vous
prévoyez notamment la possibilité de
s'affranchir de tout ou partie des
obligations de participation financière
qui pèse sur une collectivité maître
d'ouvrage lorsque d'autres personnes
publiques contribuent au financement du
projet il s'agit d'une part de
l'obligation de participation minimale
de 20% et d'autre part des fonds de
concours permettant à un EPCI à
fiscalité propre et ses communes membres
de contribuer aux investissements des
uns et des autres c'est une bonne idée
même si vous le savez vous ne régler
rien sur le fond c'est bien évidemment
l'État c'est à dire les contribuables
qui vont être contraints une fois encore
de mettre la main à la poche avec à la
clé une double peine payer la réparation
des équipements qu'ils ont déjà payé
parce qu'il y a urgence pour la
reconstruction je voterai ces
dispositions bien sûr mais les casseurs
dans tout ça il est vrai que si l'on en
croit à la député Sandrine Rousseau
malheureusement elle est absente les
pilleurs volent dans les magasins qu'il
casse parce qu'ils sont pauvres et s'ils
sont pauvres ils ne peuvent pas
rembourser des dégâts c'est QFD on ne
peut même plus parler de naïveté ou
d'absurdité non il s'agit tout
simplement de complicité
l'exact contraire de ce qu'attend la
grande majorité des Français mais on
devra se contenter du flyer du garde des
sceaux Eric Dupond-Moretti à destination
des parents pour expliquer en terme
simple à ceux qui les auraient oubliés
quels sont leurs obligations êtes-vous
vraiment sérieux il faut poser des actes
forts et pour les mineurs ces petits
voyous ces casseurs c'est pilleurs cela
passe par la responsabilité la
responsabilisation financière par an par
des travaux d'intérêt général
systématique pour nettoyer et réparer
les dégâts commis par la restauration de
l'autorité à l'école avec un recentrage
sur le français et l'éducation civique
et morale par le développement des
internats et des centres éducatifs
fermés par la remise en cause de
l'excuse de minorité par la construction
de nouvelles places de prison évidemment
nous n'en prenons pas le chemin une fois
encore une fois de trop vous allez
consciencieusement mettre la poussière
sur le thème sous le tapis jusqu'à quand
et si nous regardions les choses en face
l'argent ne règlera pas tout nous le
savons il faut surtout s'interroger sur
la haine qui anime ces casseurs et ses
voleurs la haine de notre pays oui je
dis bien notre pays tant il ne le vivent
pas comme le leur ils sont français mais
seulement de papier et beaucoup parmi
vous continuez à nier le lien entre ces
émeutes et une immigration de masse non
choisi
non contrôler continuez comme ça et nous
nous retrouverons ici pour déplorer
encore plus de dégâts et qui sait cette
fois pas un mort
est mort merci
et bien la discussion générale est close
et monsieur le ministre vous souhaitiez
dire quelques mots vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vais être bref
parce que globalement mon souhait c'est
évidemment que nous puissions adopter ce
texte d'urgence y compris en nous
appliquant à nous-mêmes le principe de
l'urgence dans la manière d'avancer je
veux simplement dire qui a eu des
questions qui posaient sur une partie du
texte on va y répondre article par
article et il y a eu des interpellations
sur les causes je le redis ça c'est un
sujet qui mérite mieux que quelques
heures au mois de juillet et qui
nécessitera d'être traité les yeux
ouverts à la rentrée avec juste une
condition c'est que chacun n'entre pas
dans l'hémicycle en disant ça fait des
années que je le dis et j'ai raison
parce que si on présente les choses de
cette manière là bizarrement il y a des
gens qui rentreront dans cette hémicycle
en disant des choses absolument
contraire et en étant dans une espèce de
logique de prophétie autorialisatrice
qui ne correspond pas à ce que nous
avons vécu